[Music]
on this wednesday night the finance
minister's
41 thousand dollar revelation i want to
apologize for this error
bill mourinho admits he just repaid tens
of thousands of dollars to the we
charity
for a trip he and his family took three
years ago you just repaid it today
on the same day you were expected to
testify under oath about it
is that just a coincidence minister what
could ruin plans to go back to class
we will almost certainly identify cases
of covid19
in students and staff in the fall new
warnings about a summer surge of covid19
and what it could lead to
and separating fact from falsehoods
about face masks i'm just tired of all
the
conflicting information we uncover the
truth
global national with donna friesen
[Music]
good evening and thanks for joining us
canada's finance minister has admitted
he made a big financial mistake
bill morneau says he wrote a check today
for more than 41 thousand dollars
to repay the we charity for trips he and
his family took back in 2017.
the surprise came during mourinho's
appearance before the finance committee
it's probing mourinho and prime minister
justin trudeau's role in a cabinet
decision to award a multi-million dollar
contract
to we to run a student grant program the
opposition had plenty of questions today
including
how does anyone forget they owed forty
one thousand dollars
abigail beeman is following this for us
tonight abigail well donna some
late breaking news here following an
afternoon of explosive
testimony by the finance minister we now
know the prime minister will testify at
the very same committee
that's a rare event his office says the
timing is still being worked out
i want to apologize for this error on my
part it's a mistake
i think it was a mistake on my part
innumerable maya culpa's from a finance
minister who tried to explain why
earlier in the day he wrote a check to
we for tens of thousands of dollars
for two family trips to kenya in 2017
and ecuador of which he'd already paid
52
000 in personal expenses but didn't know
about the rest
today i wrote a check in payment of 41
thousand dollars 366.
i expected and always had intended to
pay the full cost of these trips
and it was my responsibility to make
sure that was done
not doing so even unknowingly is not
appropriate
i want to apologize for this error the
average canadian
living in red deer or halifax that goes
on a trip
would notice if there was a
say a 400 expense that they didn't pay
maybe a hotel room for a couple of
nights that never got charged them and
they
paid immediately but you're telling me
that on this obviously very luxurious
trip
that 41 000 dollars of expenses
happened right under your nose
and you didn't know about it until it
suddenly through an epiphany
came to your attention the very day you
were to testify
in a parliamentary committee about it
but there's more mourinho's family also
made
two 50-thousand dollar donations to we
one in june of 2018 and one in june of
this year related to covet 19
the same month the prime minister
announced we would lead the 900 million
dollar student grant program
i formally asked the ethics commissioner
to review this information as part of
his examination
have you read the conflict of interest
act i believe when i first came into
office i would have had
access to all of those uh those acts if
you don't really remember the conflict
of interest act you remember the agga
khan
ruling by the ethics commissioner
because it seems that he made direct
rulings about a situation that you are
now
in isn't there someone in your office
who would
tell you come on minister these are the
these are the rules these this is the
law
of the land it applies to you as well
conservatives are calling for his
resignation
mourinho says he'll keep working for
canadians
abigail there is another threat to this
story the contract the government
awarded to we and then canceled went to
the we charity
foundation not the wheat charity itself
why is that raising red flags
well donna that's a separate entity that
only received charitable status
last year its stated purpose is to hold
tens of millions of dollars in real
estate
a charity lawyer tells global news this
revelation is
shocking it would be like saying
i gave money to a particular charity but
in fact you gave it to a different one
it certainly doesn't reflect well in
terms of the transparency that we've
seen
on this particular deal as soon as the
deal became very controversial
they should have just released all the
information especially the agreement
now we tells global news the use of
multiple entities is not uncommon saying
it made the foundation the quote
contracting party with the government on
the advice of its lawyers to protect
wee's we charities pre-existing
charitable assets
donna all right abigail beeman
in ottawa lots of questions the
opposition wants an independent
investigation
into launched into harassment
allegations that have emerged
about the governor general cbc news
quotes anonymous sources who say
they quit working at rideau hall because
governor general julie payet created
what they call a toxic environment
the report alleges payette yelled at
belittled and publicly humiliated
employees
global news has corroborated the claims
with a former rideau hall employee
the office of the governor general
denies the allegations the statement
says we deeply regret this reporting
which is in stark contrast to the
reality of working at the osgg
it goes on to say no formal complaint
regarding harassment has been made
the ndp leader jagmeet singh says the
government and the prime minister in
particular
must look into the allegations there is
no question there is an
obligation a responsibility of the prime
minister in this case with the governor
general and the complaints that we've
seen
to to do something to follow up with
those complaints
and and that needs to happen
every canadian has the right to a safe
secure workspace
free from uh harassment and that is
extremely important that's why we
move forward on june 22nd with
announcements on
strengthening the oversight in federally
regulated agencies and environments
including the public service
the prime minister has not said if he
will conduct a formal investigation
payet herself has not commented on the
allegations
in a landmark decision that could have
lasting effects on both sides of the
border a federal judge has ruled
canada's safe
third country agreement violates the
charter of rights and freedoms
the agreement requires refugee claim and
seek protection in the first safe
country they arrive in
under the agreement those that arrive at
an official point of entry on land from
the u.s are ineligible to make a refugee
claim in canada
in her ruling judge anne marie mcdonald
says there is significant evidence
ineligible claimants returned to the u.s
under the agreement face risks and
challenges of being detained as a
penalty
she emphasized canada couldn't turn a
blind eye to evidence
this immigration lawyer says the ruling
makes sense
the surprising thing uh
is that it took this long what appears
to be happening in the united states
is a policy of discouraging refugees
and that now has been the
sort of the crack in the armor of this
safety country agreement
the ruling gives parliament six months
to respond before invalidating the safe
third country agreement we know parents
across the country are wondering as
september edges closer whether their
kids will be back
in the classroom several provinces are
rolling out their back to school plans
there's a chance though they could be
derailed if the number of kovid 19 cases
keeps rising
as they have been in canada's four
largest provinces many cases are linked
to bars restaurants and parties where
younger people
are coming into close contact with each
other
[Music]
this is a beach in vancouver stanley
park last night crowds of people packed
a weekly drum
circle held on the beach there though
many people are following public health
guidance
it's clear some are not and because of
that public health officers fear there
could be an explosive rise
in cases as heather urex west reports
the provinces are banking on good
behavior to get children back in school
by the fall
when students in nova scotia head back
to class this september
a lot of things will have changed mass
will be mandatory on buses
and in the hallways in common areas of
high schools and anyone who wants to
wear a mask
for their own benefit is free to do so
there will be
no lockers and young students will be
placed in cohorts
all in an effort to prevent the spread
of covid19
though health officials admit classrooms
cannot be made risk-free
we will almost certainly identify cases
of covid19
in students and staff in the fall in
alberta where mask use among students
will not be
required in-person learning is set to
resume as well
even though infections in that province
are on the rise
new case counts in alberta are now among
the highest per capita in the country
and have risen sharply over the last few
weeks on july 1
30 new cases were reported on tuesday
that number was up to 141
i am concerned by the continued rise in
active cases
our health system is watching the
situation closely but i want to be clear
we all have a role to play in reducing
the rise in cases that we are seeing
the best thing that we can do to protect
people in school
is keep community transmission to the
lowest rate possible
social gatherings among younger adults
have become a source of concern for
health officials
many of the country's most recent
infections have been among this
demographic
if current trends continue or if the
number of percent positive cases climbs
past 3 percent
this infectious disease doctor believes
policymakers will have to take a harder
line
hopefully we don't see that but if
you're starting to see indications of
that
we're going to have to re-evaluate what
we're doing and perhaps
pull back in certain realms it's why
calgary city council voted to make mask
wearing mandatory while inside public
places
one of the main reasons we did this was
so we can get our hands around the
current outbreak which is scary and big
so that kids can go back to school and
with the school year a little more than
a month away
there is little time to waste heather
urex west global news
calgary
saskatchewan is reporting its highest
number of daily new cases today since
the start of this pandemic
60 more positive cases were reported 43
of them are people living in one
hunterite colony about 200 kilometers
west of regina
a total of 17 hutterite colonies in
saskatchewan
are now dealing with outbreaks the
premier is urging people to stay in
their own communities as much as
possible
to help limit the spread the united
states is on track to hit another
disturbing milestone in this pandemic
nearly 4 million americans have now
tested positive for the virus
and those are just the official numbers
experts say there are likely many more
undetected cases and in a sign of how
this pandemic is progressing
california now has surpassed new york as
the state with the most confirmed cases
more than 413 000 people there have
tested positive
after months of downplaying the crisis
president donald trump now admits it
will get
worse before it gets better jackson
prescott reports
in hidalgo county texas hospitals
morgues and funeral homes are at the
breaking point
we normally do about maybe six to ten
funerals a month
and right now we're doing almost 10 a
week
out of desperation local officials
issued a stay-at-home order
the state of texas blocked them from
enforcing it unfortunately
you know our hospital rooms look like
warsaw in california
a new daily record with nearly 13 000
new cases reported in just 24 hours
the u.s military has sent teams to
strained hospitals
as the virus surges in more and more new
places the lack of a coordinated
national strategy has left a patchwork
of responses and requirements
new york expanded its quarantine to
travelers from 31 states
including maryland where officials in
baltimore ordered restaurants and bars
to close their doors after a sudden
increase in cases
what we really need is a national
mandate from the top
to indicate what we need to be doing to
protect one another
it will probably unfortunately get worse
before it gets better
tuesday's frank admission from president
donald trump does not change the fact
that the virus is still running rampant
the virus will disappear it will
disappear states continue to grapple
with testing shortages and climbing
rates of death and hospitalization
the top infectious disease expert in the
u.s issued a blunt warning that it may
not be enough
i think we ultimately will get control
of it i don't really see us eradicating
it
but with many states refusing to roll
back their reopenings while pushing
ahead with plans to get kids back into
the classroom in just a few weeks
there seems to be few options left for
bringing the virus under control
jackson proskow global news washington
new details about the case of two quebec
girls murdered by their father
coming up what the police reveal about
the timeline
last week search teams spent days in a
wooded area outside quebec city looking
for marten carpontier
and his two daughters today the police
said they now have evidence
all three of them were dead before that
search even began
as mike armstrong explains investigators
believe carpentier killed his daughters
and himself
within hours of a mysterious car
accident and a warning this story does
contain
disturbing details
police now admit that even before they
issued an amber alert it appears
all three people they were looking for
were already dead
the question then is why it took so long
nearly a day
well everything investigators had in the
first hours after the girls disappeared
said their father wasn't a threat that
includes talking to family
we weren't worried that the father would
hurt the daughters
the night of july 8th martenka ponci had
taken his daughters for ice cream they
were headed in the direction of their
mother's home
as though they were going to be dropped
off but they never made it
there was a single car crash an accident
police say around this spot
the three were last seen on foot
crossing the highway and headed into the
forest
it would take searchers three days to
find the girls bodies
but police now believe they were dead
within 12 hours
while the daughters had been hurt in a
car crash
they were killed they were killed by a
blunt object used by the suspect
at that place at that area now also in
those first hours police believe
caprancia killed himself they now
confirmed they had checked the spot
where his body was found in fact
twice the force was just too dense to
see it they defend being tight-lipped
during the search they say they didn't
want to give details about what they
were doing or
call kakpanzi a suspect in case he was
listening
but they insist they tried everything
including when they found one of
carpancy's
sandals investigators went as far as
walking barefoot
to see how difficult it was to move in
that forest not wearing any shoes that's
how far we went
the criminal part of this investigation
is now over
the job of trying to explain what
happened and why
now falls to the coroner mike armstrong
global news
montreal still ahead the fire in france
that forced two boys to make a brave
[Applause]
jump
there was no time to hesitate as this
apartment in southeastern france went up
in flames two young boys
you can see there jumped from their
third story window thankfully a group of
people was there on the ground to catch
them
the boys aged 10 and 3 weren't injured
local media reports they were taken to
the hospital
for smoke inhalation china is promising
to retaliate after the u.s
government ordered the chinese consulate
in houston texas
to be shut down within 72 hours smoke
was seen rising from
inside the consulate compound last night
as aerial footage appeared to show
staff burning documents the trump
administration
says the decision to close the
diplomatic mission was done
in order to protect intellectual
property and the private information of
americans
it's an unprecedented move in the 41
years since china and the u.s
established diplomatic relations china
has five consulates in the u.s
plus its embassy in washington
unmasking myths next fact-checking
claims
about face masks
[Music]
this was prince philip's first public
appearance in months he took part in a
military ceremony at windsor castle the
99 year old duke of edinburgh has
formally retired from royal duties but
he does still keep active
a parallel ceremony was held to welcome
his daughter-in-law the duchess of
cornwall
camilla as the new colonel in chief of
the rifles
and prince george showed off a gap-tooth
grin and new photos released to mark his
seventh birthday they were taken last
month by his mother kate middleton
george is the eldest of kate and prince
william's three children
well to mask or not to mask that really
shouldn't be a question anymore covering
our nose and mouth
does reduce the risk of spreading
covid19 to other people
health officials around the world all
agree that wearing a non-medical mask in
situations when we can't be physically
distant from other people
is one of the key ways of limiting a new
pandemic surge
but there's a great deal of misleading
information out there that some people
are latching onto
as an excuse not to put on a mask so we
send our jeff simple
on a myth busting mission about masks
it's fast become a familiar sight across
the country
marches against mandatory masks
i'm just tired of all the conflicting
information that we're getting from
different sources and he's not wrong a
quick search online
turns up a ton of conflicting claims
warnings that masks weaken your immune
system
increase toxins and carbon dioxide and
decrease
oxygen causing brain damage even death
that really doesn't make any biological
sense to me
and it's ironic because actually cobit
does decrease oxygen absorption coverage
causes brain damage
so this is an oxygen sat probe we put
that theory to the test
checking my oxygen levels while wearing
a surgical mask
then a regular cloth mask and finally
a medical grade n95 mask
and a hundred percent as you can see the
oxygen saturation doesn't change
whatever mask you're wearing
i even tried wearing all three masks
simultaneously
at 99 with altery masks they're not
comfortable but
i know dr thasleem nimji and her
colleagues wear masks
all day every day for long procedures
surgeons and and those in the room are
wearing masks and able to perform your
surgery without any
concern about their own safety on this
canadian facebook page
users share tips on how to circumvent
mandatory masks
and claim the virus can easily slip
through the cracks
kovit 19 is indeed tiny around
microns but it doesn't travel solo the
particle attaches itself to a much
larger droplet or aerosol and studies
have shown that good quality cotton
masks prevent more than 85 percent of
those particles from escaping the key is
also the material
if you do them like a two layer
codon based fabric mask would offer
quite a good protection scarves and
t-shirts are thought to be less
effective
but experts admit there's still much
they don't know
we're still exploring uh the efficacy of
masks
as a strategy to stop the spread
of kobit 19. and and when you have
uncertain science
it can be more difficult to to pass on
to the public a clear
message what is clear is that the
benefits of masks far outweigh the risks
and in the absence of a vaccine could be
our best weapon
jeff sample global news toronto
and that is global national for this
wednesday i'm donna friesen tonight here
in canada is the city of swift current
saskatchewan also known as
speedy creek we'd love to see your
canada please email it to viewers at
globalnational.com
thanks for watching hope to see you here
again tomorrow take care of yourselves
[Music]
bye-bye
[Music]
you